so we're continuing to cover as we've
done on the bonus show the detention and
imprisonment and trial of wnba player
brittany greiner
in russia and unfortunately
the situation itself is sort of opaque
and the russian justice system is not
exactly what we would call
fair and open the prosecution rate is
you know outrageously high and there's
all sorts of history there of everything
from planted evidence to everything you
can imagine and also it does appear from
the reports we have now that brittany
greiner
supposedly accidentally had a very very
small amount of drugs with her
in russia and the united states is now
trying to get her out of what they
consider to be
an unjust detention and there is a
prisoner swap that is now being
considered well donald trump is siding
with russia on this one again
trump sides with russia calls jailed
american brittany griner spoiled
donald trump appeared on the
what show is this we've seen clips the
clay travis and buck sexton show
and says brittany griner is spoiled
and he wouldn't have made this deal to
get her out would you have made by the
way the offer for brittany griner and
victor bout that russia has put forward
where they'll trade this arms dealers 25
years for arms dealing all over the
world for the wnba player and also i
believe a former marine is being held
there
she went in there loaded up with drugs
into a hostile territory with okay
loaded up with drugs we're going to talk
about in a moment they're very vigilant
about drugs they don't like drugs
and she got caught
and by the way
trump loves
when authoritarian strong men
just go crazy about anything drug
related he thought it was amazing that
duterte used to kill drug dealers and
trump recently said for every drug
dealer you kill you save 500 people how
he came up with that number i don't know
we're supposed to get her and she makes
a you know a lot of money i guess
but we're supposed to get her out for a
absolute
killer
and one of the biggest arms dealers in
the world killed many americans killed
many people
and he's going to get a free card
and
we're gonna get her she knew you don't
go in there loaded up with drugs and she
admitted it
i assume she admitted it without too
much force because it is what it is
and it's sometimes there's force but
okay it doesn't seem like a very good
trade does it
he's an absolute one of the worst in the
world and he's going to be given his
freedom
because a
potentially spoiled person goes into
russia loaded up with drugs
okay
now what by spoiled does he just mean
that she's black like is this as simple
as she's gay and black which to trump
means that she's spoiled first of all
trump has pardoned tons of criminals
that's number one so clearly there's not
in principle a problem he has
with saying here's someone who's been
sentenced for something
but i'm gonna pardon them trump talks
about loaded up with drugs
i'm right there in saying when you go
places like russia
you've got to be really careful about
what you have with you i'm i'm right
there in fact i don't think i would even
go
uh
she had 0.7 grams of cannabis oil now
that's legal in her home state of
arizona it's legal in many states in the
united states it's not legal in russia i
completely am with you there but
0.7 grams is not exact exactly being
loaded up with drugs
and yet the russian media
has referred to it as a significant
amount of drugs that's obviously not
true she also had a doctor's note for
the cannabis oil i understand that
doesn't make it legal in russia but she
explained that
she pleaded guilty she said it was
inadvertent you know it's like we've got
madison cawthorne quote accidentally
bringing gun trying to bring guns past
tsa onto planes
multiple times
and the right is perfectly satisfied
saying those are honest mistakes here's
0.7 grams of cannabis oil with a
doctor's note and now all of a sudden
we're supposed to believe her detention
is fair and not at all politically
motivated so
you knew that trump was going to come up
with something like this
but the pattern is
once again he's defending russia and
russia's authoritarian police state
their completely absurd justice system
i was let me see if i can even find it
um russian court's
conviction rate
in 2018 the gross conviction rate i
believe gross means it doesn't account
for repeals and reversals the gross
conviction rate was 99
yeah there you go in 2018
0.25
of russian court cases ended in an
acquittal
that's an incredibly efficient judicial
system isn't it so listen i i get it you
got to be careful whenever i go anywhere
i make sure to bring nothing i don't
bring anything there and i don't bring
anything back
that's my thing but 0.7 grams of
cannabis oil and now trump goes oh well
she's spoiled
give me a break absolutely outrageous